we have a problem at the border now I'm
a I'm not a child I'm a child of
privilege but if you look back at you
know my history going back to the 19th
century as Italians and Irish they were
not
treated well if you look and I know
American history okay if you look at how
Chinese were treated in the early 20th
century how women were treated how
blacks were treated how gays were
treated every generation discriminates
against somebody and the Next Generation
has to reverse it
and some of that's relating to
immigration people are saying immigrants
are not only bad but they're giving
American people a sense that immigrants
are dirty and every one of us I'd like
to ask a Native American what do you
think of immigrants but um the fact is
that immigration is a problem there are
too many immigrants taking advantage of
the system there's a uh I thought an
underreported story this week about how
the White House is giving more
administrative authority to immigration
officials to reject people I think
that's part of the answer we should be
setting a far higher bar for who gets in
here and also supporting who gets over
that bar much more aggressive you really
saying that yes if people a lot of
people would agree with you on that it
took us a long time to come to America I
went to Germany at a refuge again before
I came here we had to sacrifice uh
parents getting the divorce our entire
money that we had everything just to
come to America so I I uh I think a lot
of people in America as a as a person I
was born in Iran 10 years there two
years in Germany at a refuge Camp year
and a half that finally made it here I
value this place a ton on how long it
took us to get here it was a dream the
day but then but then to be clear when
you get here support for your children
food and kindergarten support for for
your family in terms of medical care
there's a cost whose job is that though
I'd say partly that it's the job of the
government why is that the government's
job to educate a child no no public
school you're right no no public school
you're right but but what is my my
responsibility when I do I do you owe me
more or do I owe you more if I come here
I think both oh I disagree I disagree
how could you say that how could you say
that well how can a person I pay a lot
of taxes that person's not going to pay
a lot I just paid a lot for them to go
to school I don't have kids wait let me
get this straight so an immigrant is
wanting to come to your house yes I want
to come to your country yes you owe me
the same amount as I owe you I owe you a
lot no no you don't know me bro that's
incorrect I I owe you I you want to
disagree you want to yell it but no I'll
come across the table I'll crush you
like a bug I'd love to see it but the
point I'm trying to make to you right
now is the following I feel I feel I owe
you
I feel I agree with you okay so that's
the part where a little bit of the
mindset right now is the fact that
people are saying America owes the
Immigrant I don't agree with that I
think I think if I uh so for example
let's just say Goldman Sachs gives me an
opportunity to work for them okay if I
work for Goldman Sachs Goldman Sachs was
here before I was here I owe Goldman
Sachs for the opportunity Michael Jordan
is about the LeBron says we should
retire to number 23 permanently Michael
Jordan says listen man this league is
bigger than one player Jordan owes the
league more than the league owes Jordan
well I mean the Immigrant owes America
this whole concept about America owes
the Immigrant I never came here thinking
America owes me anything I think you're
misunderstanding me yeah I have a couple
things to say first of all to be clear
why what I said before I get well we
will get attacked from both sides I
think the bar should be higher but when
someone gets here there's a couple
things that go on to be idealistic if
you're a human being I want to give you
the right to life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness totally good but
there's there's a brutal economic piece
and that is as someone who pays like I
say a ton of taxes without kids so I'm
paying for other kids to go to school
I'm paying for for everybody who doesn't
believe in socialism then I get to pay
the same taxes you do and I don't we
have socialism in this country and that
part of that means I pay a ton more than
you do and you use the same services
but my point is just to be purely and
brutally economic a child who goes
through a good education particularly at
the primary level if that child doesn't
have access to food I want them to have
access to food if they don't have access
to Medical Care I want them to because I
want to ensure that I don't have to pay
for them in the back end to pay for
somebody if a child is educated and
healthy the chance that they'll
contribute and I'm talking about money
they're going to get a better job
they're going to be less likely to use
Public Services they're going to be less
likely in older age to be unhealthy
they're going to pay more in taxes so I
I there's a there's a brutal economic
piece to what I'm saying as well so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]